[Musica]
ciao sono degni lazzari comunque ragazzi
siamo oggi facciamo video un po
particolare ho un amico che fa il
pizzaiolo che ha aperto un ristorante a
milano tra l'altro che è questo posso
ancora peggiorare il tipo di pizza che
posso provare nella mia vita oggi
abbiamo deciso di fare una pizza agli
insetti ma venite con me
abbiamo il costo è il nome titolo come
titolo sul signore se anche questi
luoghi
sarà il nostro assaggiatore vero certo
noi sgr e allora andiamo o l'ha duro
stop basilico
dobbiamo fare una pizza per andare
contro la patria però io vi voglio bene
sufficiente mi sta involando premi sono
ancora fatto perché via che si mette a
fare ste cagate oggi faremo la pizza
agli insetti alfonso è stato di gentile
da te recuperare queste che
all'apparenza possono sembrare
scatolette nel tè queste marcia questa è
l'inglese breakfast però se noi
l'apriamo c'è non c'è dentro st
non riesco neanche più caso
della buste ma ragazzi e grosso come
ryanair da destra di x men te l'ho
mangiata con doppio fluido e stato
subito nella mail che alzano subito ecco
busta al gusto di timo e origano no
ragazzi al bello e mai però nel momento
vai vai secondo me è croccante fuori e
morbido dentro
e
stata mattina mentre la quale questo mi
sentivo le alette pezzi di ali tra i
denti mi sento tutti gli insetti di
tutti che fanno così dentro la bocca
io io non lo ha obbligato è affatto lui
quindi la recensione stata positiva se
io da cinque generazioni mi sa che non
aveva mai più dove oggi pratici che mi
per questo video si si
forzano wieser etano vite forzano
teoricamente questi dovrebbero essere
questi green utilizzate in codice sconto
famiglie e mangiano per 21 per cento di
sconto facciamo stabili ma io sono
salite di sentiamo anche lo so non
immagina cosa sta parla questo è
l'impasto all'impasto posso provare
agosto è
bravo è giusto no questo è questa
sì attacco perché mettere il mattino la
perché avevo preparato qui l'età che la
insieme
alla bisogna prima testarla con le dita
sporche o facendo bene no non me l'ha
mai continua così bravo
vabbè più o meno se si bellissimo se
non vogliamo la tua recensione anche su
questo che ne pensi della sua
terrificante e poi mettiamo la non
salerno bravo alfonso pepe un pizzico
suo capo di piacere preparando un
ragazzo che sta imparando a
non sentire in sé non si deve sentire un
po di volere aiuto negativa ma si
staccano i pezzi
ma duramente impongono mezzo di mezz'ora
un
mare che cosa dove ci vivo e quindi
metto la spada ma è grossa non salterà
vinto e fatto una stagione già finita
guardate qua c'è una vita un secondo
treno ogni 30 secondi ma per
secondo hai vissuto in una menzogna la
pizza la fanno in 30 secondi vedo che ci
sono 50 anni di serie perché sei stronzo
che ci ha provato
[Musica]
ora mi chiama mia madre mi fa oggi anche
lo so che ti abbiamo adottato i ragazzi
questa è la mia pizza o quest'acqua è
ora che ho fatto io
la borchia ora che ho finito la mia
pizza andiamo a metterci gli ingredienti
speciali
no no no ragazzi va no no no no
terrificante sto per fare della
cittadinanza non italiana proprio vuoi
mettere non più di una cavalletta
perfetta che la devo mangiare io grazie
al meno giusto per non farmi vomitare
posso dare una spolveratina di vermi ma
che bello e buono come si muovono col
calore assaggiamo sai assaggiava allora
sulla cresta stessa fretta è bella
proprio per tali
eccoci qua bona beh siamo contenti per
si vide bravi ragazzi grazie mi
accompagnati ste cagate propri fermenti
se tizio è bene e pergo e vergognoso
vergognoso facciamo sesso quasi 500
smetta aspetto il massimo e poi
inghiottì e basta penso alla fame nel
mondo però perso punto sì quando si
formano bastoni
[Musica]
già
prof 3 2 1 adesso il
problema è la cavalletta ragazzi
veramente un problema così il problema
mi la cavalletta io sono un problema e
la cavalletta qui che in contante il
ragazzo è una missione di pensiero
perché non riguarda
ho detto che buona pizza
normale dove in tutti la miglior
ingeteam insieme
29 non solo mai che lo stesso centro le
zampine sì anch'io hai capito che come
quando hai un pelo e petrolo dagli
mattino senti ancora la stessa cosa
comunque questo video finisce qua
ringraziamo alfo per aver perso la
licenza alla pizzaiolo per aver preso
qualsiasi cosa tu ingala di famiglie
grazie che mi avete accompagnato da una
ripresa più forti della mia vita
preferisco forse il bungee jumping che
ho fatto non sono giunte e adesso
ragazzi per concludere il video lorenzo
assaggerà un'ultima che la locusta buon
fine video o scrivete i ragazzi
iscrivetevi